attente étrangère
Je devrais vous avertir avant que vous n'entriez dans
la maison cela pourrait changer le cours
de toute votre vie Je n'ai pas peur d'un
couple va
vous dire que maintenant
[Musique]
ce manoir est déséquilibré
ces fantômes ne veulent certainement pas partir
des clercs de la mort à chaque coin de rue
Dieu nous donne une pause il y a tellement de mauvaises
personnes dans le monde qui les hantent amen
j'aime bien si
quelqu'un d'autre voit ça
vous le faites nous nous disputons que cela nous plaise
ou non ou bien nous sommes coincés ici  pour
l'éternité
si cela se résume à un exorcisme ou à un
gros problème
cette maison
Des âmes mais il y a toujours de la place
pour une de plus
mon ami s'est fait agresser il était grand il avait des
cheveux qui sortaient d'un quel
chapeau haut de forme Haut de forme oui oui Haut de forme vous  en
tirerait probablement un lapin euh
les yeux ils étaient un peu euh quelque chose de
gentil comme un [ __ ] laveur quand ils s'assoient
et il souriait comme ouais comme ça
exactement est-ce l'homme qui t'a agressé
wow tu viens de faire ça tout à l'heure
étranger